Speaker 1: There's a very interesting
article from The New York Times called
Trump's Legal Defense Legal Team
Scrambling to find an argument.
And this article really puts in focus that there
is no defense here. So far, the strategy has been
throw everything you can at the wall, whether
it's catch up or whatever else you have,
throw it all at the wall and see what sticks.
You might remember that at one point when we
started learning about these documents at
Mar a Lago. At one point the argument was
there were no documents there that were controlled
by or taken by Trump that was all planted by the
FBI. That was one argument they threw at the wall.
It didn't stick. So very quickly that changed to
it wasn't illegal for Trump to have these
documents at his house because Trump is the
president can declassify whatever materials
he wants. And also laws governing classified
materials don't even apply to presidents of the
United States. Well, but so hold on a second.
Were they planted by the FBI or did he have them
but they were declassified or did he have them and
they were classified, but it didn't matter because
he used to be the president. Which is it? But then
we learned, oh, the crimes he's being investigated
for, it's not actually relevant whether they were
or were not classified because of how the laws
actually are around the documents that he had. Oh,
well, so forget all of that anyway. For that,
then none of that matters. So then it was listen.
We cooperated. Trump cooperated all along. Trump
returned the documents. Trump stored the documents
behind a lock and key at Mar a Lago, just like
he was asked to do. But then we got the affidavit
unsealed. And in the affidavit, there was nothing
about a lock. It just. There was just nothing
about a lock. The story they kept telling us. We
were told put a lock on the door, and then you'll.
You'll be all good. The affidavit doesn't say
anything about a lock. It was about concerns as
to how they were being stored, but nothing about
a lock. So then some of Donald Trump's advisers
have started to insist, well, it wasn't Trump
who moved and put the documents there anyway.
It was the General Services Administration.
So you've got to go and talk to the General
Services Administration, except the GSA has
completely denied this. We didn't we didn't
take any documents. We didn't put any documents
in Mar a Lago. This has absolutely nothing to do
with us. So then at another point, they shifted
to Obama did it, too, with 30,000 documents, not
with 300 or 700 or whatever the number is. That's
not true, and it's also irrelevant. You can't say,
Listen, I may have murdered someone, but
other murders have been committed as well,
so you can't come after me. Unfortunately or
fortunately, depending on your perspective,
that's not the way the legal system works. Then
they followed it and this one is just so absurd.
They floated. Trump likes to take work home. A
for a job he no longer has. He's no longer the
president of the United States. What does that
mean? And then Trump wanted these documents for
his memoirs, folks. Trump doesn't read or write.
What are you talking about? Trump wanted these
for his memoirs, so the reality is very quickly
becoming. There is no explanation that makes
sense. And Trump's cadre of lawyers, some of whom
he reportedly hired just from seeing them on TV,
is having a serious problem now and
figuring out how are we going to
mount a legal defense here? They will mount
one. How are we going to mount a coherent
legal defense if and or when Donald Trump is
indeed indicted, it's going to be quite a mess